hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his proma to any future
metaphysics near the end of the first
part of the main transcendental question
in remark three Emanuel Kant is going to
tackle the question of Illusion shine
and Truth V height right and usually we
would oppose falsity to truth but here
he's opposing illusion being mistaken
about something he'll also use the word
irum at a certain point in this
discussion error right going
astray and he begins this remark by
saying there's an accusation that's
being made Against My
Philosophy by our admitting the
ideality of space and time the whole
sensible world would be turned into a
mere illusion the term there is shine
right so it's not just an illusion as
opposed to a truth but the entire
sensible World becomes just a a figment
of our imagination and this is you know
an accusation of a certain kind of
idealism as he's going to talk about in
this remark and this is a very common
criticism that is made by certain
critics of Emmanuel Kant I mean we could
say that perhaps they were
less attentive readers of the critique
of pure reason who got this wrong and K
is resp responding to them but he could
also be responding to people all the way
down to the present who are let's say
less excusable as inattentive sloppy
ideologically biased readers of Kant You
can disagree with Kant and say ah he's
got some of these things wrong but you
actually do have to get correct what it
is that he's saying and you do have to
take into account you know clear
statements of what he in fact does
believe or endorse or doesn't so the
people who are out there in the present
saying oh yes Kant you know reduces the
whole sensible world to Mere illusion we
lose our track of things we don't have
any sort of realistic relation to
objects well those are kind of off base
and Kant has responses to them as well
and he begins with something that he
calls a correction and idea here is that
previous philosophers have been getting
something wrong and what does he have in
mind here I would say that this
certainly applies to the rationalist
tradition we see dekart and liet making
statements like this about sensibility I
would say this also applies to the
empiricist tradition as well so in their
view as he says it uh philosophical
insight into the nature of sensuous
cognition was spoiled Why by making
sensibility merely a confused foror uh
mode of representation the the German
text actually just says representation
for right so according to this we still
know things as they are but without
being able to reduce everything in this
representation to a clear Consciousness
so when I'm sensing something I am
representing it to myself in my mind but
in a less clear way than say pure logic
or you know mathematics or anything that
could be you know relations of ideas as
David Hume was calling them and then he
says whereas on the contrary proof is
offered by us that sensibility consists
not in this logical
distinction of uh clearness
clar height or obscurity dlight again
terminology that's being used by earlier
modern philosophers uh but rather in the
genetic one of the
origin of cognition itself where are the
cognitions coming from what faculties
are actually providing us with these and
and how are we related to an external
world through these cognitions these of
what we seem to be thinking of as real
things so he goes on and he says
sensuous perception represents things
not at all as they are but only in the
mode in which they affect our senses so
by sensuous perception we get
appearances and not things themselves
and these are given to the understanding
for reflection so important point being
made here and you know Kant is saying
don't mix me up with these people over
here that have got this wrong does that
get him off the hook not entirely so he
has to address this in another way and
notice what he's just said here that um
you know sensus perception represents
things uh in the way that they affect
our senses um they're given to the
understanding then for reflection
so in all of our perception we really
have two different faculties that are
working hand in hand we we have
sensibility which includes our senses
and you know putting things together we
get impressions coming in or appearances
and then we have the faculty of
understanding fishand which judges them
right so the appearance is given to us
through sensibility and then the
understanding engages in judgment the
tyen in in German
and is the other term that he uses here
for judgment which is not quite the same
thing is right but it's it's sort of an
intensification of it so he goes on and
he tells us when an appearance is given
to us we are quite free as to how we
should judge the matter now to anybody
who's a reader of modern philosophy this
want to remind you very much of Renee
decart's meditation for where he's
trying to distinguish how we actually
fall into error and how we mix up truth
truth and falsity here it's truth and
illusion and it has to do not with the
sensibility itself but rather with the
understanding and the use that we make
of our understanding which we are free
to do right so this is going to allow
him to make all sorts of great
distinctions and observations about
different ways we fall into illusion and
again we could see a reference here to
Renee diart the truth and dreaming so he
tells us that the difference between
truth and dreaming is not ascertained by
the nature of the representations which
are referred to objects because they're
the same in both cases right so when
We're Dreaming we are you know let's use
decart's example I dream that I'm
sitting in my room in a chair before the
fire that I see flickering and you know
I've got these these Sensations that are
going on we take that for real While
We're Dreaming but it it's not really
real not just because we're imagining
something that isn't
happening but because there's something
lacking and again we see this in uh both
decart's discourse and the uh
meditations he he comes to a resolution
of this and k um solution to this is
kind of similar it's not ascertained by
the nature of the representations which
are referred to objects but by their
connection
their how they're tied together linked
together according to those rules which
determine the coherence Zam and hang how
things hang
together the coherence of the
representations in the concept of the
object and ascertaining whether they can
subsist together an experience or not
you know as uh we've talked about quite
a few other people as you know Freud in
his famous work on the interpretation of
dreams will point out not you know
originally because many other people
pointed this out dreams have their own
weird logic which is not that of waking
States and K is saying you know in this
case the connection the coherence is
different in the dream than it is in our
waking State and so this is how we can
potentially tell the difference between
those we don't have to fall into
illusion of taking our dreams as being
true then he talks about uh another sort
of
modality of Illusion he says that it's
not the fault of appearances if our
cognition takes illusion for truth that
is if the
intuition by which an object is given us
so the object there is object right some
the object of the
intuition uh being given to us in in
senses is
taken for something more than it is
taken for the concept of the thing
the right the the uh um concept of
something that exists as an object for
us or even as the thing existing the
existence of that thing so we can go
wrong
by saying the appearances the
representations are providing us more
than they are and we do this by an
improper use of our understanding
applied to that intuition and he's got
an example here the senses represent to
us Paths of the planet is now
Progressive now retrogressive therein is
neither falsehood nor truth because as
long as we're just observing and we're
taking this to be appearance we're not
judging we're not making a judgment of
the objective nature of their motion but
if we start saying well they move
backwards it's not the senses which must
be charged with illusion but the
understanding whose Province alone it is
to make an objective judgment on
appearances so again not an absolutely
new doctrine here we see this in many
other philosophers that the senses
themselves don't deceive us it's rather
the use that in this case con say our
understanding will make of the
appearances that it's been given and
that's are using our faculty of um
understanding to make wrongheaded
judgments so if we want to avoid
illusion and K says we can do this even
if we're not like investigating the
origin of our representations right he
says whenever we connect our intuitions
of sense in space and time according to
the rules of the coherence of all
cognition and appearance illusion or
truth will
arise according to whether we are
negligent or careful for right attentive
is another way of thinking about so we
have control over that as well we can
pay attention or we can be laxidasical
about it and then get tricked so he's
going to go on and talk
about the use of sensuous
representations or intuitions in the
understanding uh now notice that he says
in the understanding so not just by the
understanding but within the
understanding which is part of us right
making use of
representations or
appearances in reference to uh possible
experience so if we go beyond the
boundaries of possible experience like
he says if I venture to go beyond all
possible experience with my concepts of
space and time which I cannot refrain
from doing if I do certain metaphysical
moves if I Proclaim them qualities
inherent in things of themselves uh then
a grave error irum may arise due to
illusion I Proclaim to be universally
valid what is a merely a subjective
condition of intuition of things and
certain only for all objects of sense
for all possible
experience empirical experience that I
can actually have so if we stay within
the realm of possible experience well
we're not going to get into so much
trouble right if we don't do that then
we can actually fall in to what he's
calling
transcendental illusion and he talks
about this as we get closer to the end
he tells us that if we don't adopt my
point of view on the ideality of space
and time then we're inevitably going to
wind up in the transcendental illusion
and he says what is this transcendental
illusion
done metaphysics has been deceived
hither to up to this point and misled
into childish efforts of catching at
bubbles why because appearances which
are mere
representations um are taken for things
in themselves we can't access the things
in themselves through sensibility we
can't do it through the understanding
either because the understanding applies
to matters of possible experience if we
are going to think about the things in
themselves it's going to be a different
faculty that's going to handle that and
so we don't want to mix up sensibility
or understanding with these sorts of
things because if we do why is it called
the
transcendental uh illusion he says
that um appearance as long as it's
employed and experience produces truth
the moment it transgresses goes beyond
the bounds of experience and
consequently becomes transcendent ENT it
produces nothing but illusion right so
if we want to avoid illusion then Kant
is saying hey that is up to us it's
within our control whether we fall into
illusion or not it helps to have some
information he thinks right otherwise
very smart people do fall into these
Illusions you know decart for example
you mentions uh Barkley as well but if
we have this information K says hey it's
smooth sailing after this provided we
make proper use of our understanding and
we're actually you know paying attention
to how things are and how they ought to
be rather than being negligent or being
sloppy or lazy in our thinking about
these matters so uh
ways of avoiding all sorts of Illusions
Kant is saying I'm not you know turning
the world into illusion it's actually
those guys over there who are making
mistaken metaphysics metaphysics that
actually doesn't even deserve to be
called such and his approach that he
outlines in the critique and also within
the proma will help us to avoid falling
into these errors or
illusions